[Musica]
salve
come state
veramente
qui dentro c'è una ricetta fantastica
vero invisibile ma no è invisibile ma si
sente che peccato non vedervi così pack
è bello siete vivi
siete qua siete in carne ed ossa unica
cosa tangibile
allora quando mi hanno chiesto di fare
questo intervento mi sono detta io sono
abituata a essere nascosta dietro i
testi dietro le storie
oltretutto storia che amo raccontare in
genere sono anche un po complicate ne ho
raccontato anche una su questo palco
tempo fa ho avuto questo grande onore e
devo dire leverano è un quasi una mia
seconda casa quindi la amo molto questo
paese e ha detto che dico è lì son
partita per voli pindarici con paolo
detto paolo io rischio di durare due ore
perché in b l'invisibile tanto
più una cosa intangibile più immensa e
raccontarla è difficile e ho preferito
scrivere avere il mio leggio d'attrice
che adoro io adori leggero quello che
artigianale lo adoro
e allora partiamo con le domande cos'è
l'invisibile e tutto ciò che non si vede
banale questo ammetto che banale e
scontato ma forse neanche così tanto
cos'è di noi invisibile per me è ciò di
cui siamo veramente fatti
la volpe del piccolo principe dice che
non si vede bene che col cuore
l'essenziale è invisibile agli occhi
cos'è l'essenziale è tutto ciò che non
si vede
cos'è di noi invisibile
quasi tutto credo
shakespeare ha scritto noi siamo fatti
della stessa sostanza dei sogni e nello
spazio e nel tempo di un sogno è
raccolta la nostra breve vita in fondo
ci si sveglia la mattina per poter
realizzare un sogno altrimenti perché
farlo
fosse anche soltanto il sogno di
arrivare alla fine di quella giornata
viverla godersela così come arriva a
prenderla tutta così come arriva e il
sogno
è invisibile
intangibile lo si può raccontare
la voce che lo racconta e invisibile
perché il suono è invisibile non è
tangibile
invisibile il sentimento che proviamo in
visibile ciò che resta di una carezza di
uno schiaffo di un bacio di un tocco
l'emozione di tutto ciò è invisibile
ma resta
dentro di noi
nell'anima
e l'anima è invisibile
quando va via qualcuno
in tutti i sensi o o per un viaggio o
per un trasferimento perché muore
cosa resta di quella persona certamente
non il corpo
che si disintegra prima o poi sparisce
torna polvere torna cenere se bruciamo
mio padre ha avuto un piccolo aneddoto
mio padre ha perso la mamma che aveva 4
anni poi per 40 anni è dovuto andare a
vedere la sua salma che non si decompone
va che trovo che sia una cosa
terrificante
perché noi siamo così siamo attaccati al
corpo quando invece l'essenza di quella
donna è molto di più
è quello che resta ancora nel
raccontarla in casa quindi ancora viva
e allora se ci ha fatto del male di
quella persona ci resta il rancore la
rabbia il dolore se ci ha fatto del bene
ci resta l'amore il dolore stesso ci
resta la mancanza il desiderio di
volerla rivedere o se è partita per un
viaggio ci resta l'attesa l'attesa di
vederla ritornare tutto questo è indesit
è intangibile
insomma siamo molto di più di quello che
si vede tutti noi siamo molto di più di
quello che si vede
alcuni di noi sono colpiti da patologie
io stessa
invisibile
c'è chi ce l'ha visibile una patologia
ebbene quella persona ancor di più di
chi si muove cammina falcor di più
e molto più di quello che si vede
molto molto di più di quello che si vede
dobbiamo prestare attenzione a quella
persona che era una società
dell'immagine
sembra avere una mobilità diversa è
ancora molto più di noi che possiamo
manifestarla con più facilità perché fa
una fatica doppia per farlo e
manifestare assumersi la responsabilità
di quello che è nell'essenza
uno sguardo non sono soltanto due occhi
che vedono più o meno bene o anche a
volte per nulla
molti non vedenti vedono molto meglio di
chi vede uno sguardo il nostro personale
modo di osservare le cose le persone
tutti noi abbiamo bocca naso orecchie ma
il timbro della voce l'odore delle cose
il sentire sono il nostro modo
di arrivare tutto intangibile
inspirare espirare respirare intangibile
l'area stessa invisibile ma grazie ad
essa noi ridiamo il codice c è
dimostrato che si può che avuto il coin
dice che in un momento di mancata l'area
siete suo conto che respirare non è così
scontato
non è così scontata
ed è intangibile invisibile quindi gran
parte di noi
ad esempio lei cosa sta pensando in
questo momento
ecco se non lo diceva io non lo sapevo
perché non si vede giusto esattamente
tutto quello che sto pensando l'emozione
forte che provo in questo momento mi
auguro arrivi ma passivo cura immensa e
se non ve la racconto voi non la vedete
quindi veramente siamo molto di più di
tutto questo siamo
l'amore è l'amore invisibile la fame è
invisibile la voglia di bere e
invisibile tutte le emozioni tutte le
sensazioni tutti gli stati d'animo sono
invisibili siamo fatti di
invisibile il nostro profumo è
invisibile il piacere invisibile l'odore
di c di ciò che amiamo di chi amiamo è
invisibile il profumo del buon vino oggi
ne ho avuto un buonissimo il sapore di
un cibo mangiato benissimo
tutto questo è il visibile ed è ciò che
lascia la traccia di noi quando non ci
siamo più il ricordo della voce dello
sguardo del modo di parlare di guardare
e desidero che di me
resti l'immenso invisibile e lo desidero
anche per voi che voi lasciate su questa
terra
l'immenso invisibile un ricordo
bellissimo tutti noi dobbiamo farlo per
chi resta
e di ciò secondo me siamo veramente
fatti siamo la bellezza dell'ignoto
anche la nostra identità ea questo
volevo aggiungere invisibile da volte
difficile da spiegare da manifestare
eppure è quello per cui noi esistiamo
la nostra identità e facciamo una fatica
addirittura ad assumerci questa
responsabilità perché cerchiamo di
essere come la società ci vuole vestiamo
abiti che non sono i nostri
tempo fa
soprattutto ad esempio chi ha passioni
artistiche e difficilmente si è
difficile spiegarla una passione
artistica perché
è una battuta ma non lo è la seconda
domanda è ma come vivi ma come fai ma
come campi ma come e spiegare che la
mattina non puoi fare a meno di essere
quella cosa per noi che facciamo
soprattutto teatro
questa roba ci è mancata come l'aria
perché per me è necessario stare qui che
ci siano 20 persone che ce ne quando mi
dicono e avremo poco pubblico non in
questa occasione perché voi siete tanti
per essere una situazione del genere
noi vi ringraziamo molto non importa che
ci sia una persona che ce ne siano due
non importa questo per lui essenziale ed
essenziale stare di fronte all'altro
tempo fa proprio in questa cittadina
abbiamo fatto residenza con francesco
zecca vostro concittadino straordinario
regista abbiamo messo in scena uno
spettacolo che si chiama tutti i miei
cari scritto da francesca zanni ispirato
ad una poetessa anne sexton e al sex on
the go un estratto non ve lo facciamo ve
lo leggo perché lei parlava di identità
e della difficoltà ad esempio di una
donna di poter essere artista madre
moglie insomma perché socialmente è
difficile che un uomo si chieda di
rinunciare al propria arte una donna e
un po più facile lo era allora lo è
adesso è lei diceva ho vinto il premio
pulitzer per le mie poesie e non ho
nemmeno finito le superiori non riuscivo
a concentrarmi i miei mi mandarono in
una scuola professionale per imparare ad
essere una moglie e una madre perfetta
non ci sono riusciti
le donne devono essere per loro natura
delle buone madri devono trovare la loro
realizzazione nel fare le casalinghe
nella famiglia ma essere una poetessa e
contemporaneamente moglie e madre si può
fare mi dicevano di sì ma in realtà non
si può fare mia suocera mi dice sempre
non ti bastano tuo marito le tue figlie
fa in modo che siano loro il tuo hobby
il mio obi dentro di me c'è un vortice
che gira su se stesso e non riesce a
trovare una strada per uscire a volte
esce dalle mani e volte esce dalla bocca
a volte trova un buco in mezzo alle
gambe scappa via di là voi che cosa vedi
no non fatemi domande e troppe domande
nella testa preferisco non rispondere
le domande si affollano si spingono a
negano la consapevolezza che ho di me
non ricordo più che sono e soprattutto
non so rispondere nemmeno a una di
quelle domande capisco quello che mi
chiedeva perché solo stupide trovo le
risposte ma poi le perdo inizio a
cercare tutte queste risposte nella
testa e cado in un temporale di parole
che mi il lupus dal quale lo riesco a
risalire o dentro qualcosa che non sa
come organizzarsi vede solo quello che
le hanno insegnato a vedere come devo
essere io per andare bene agli altri
quale traguardo devo raggiungere per
essere come gli altri ma io non sono
come gli altri nessuno di noi è come gli
altri
e le domande mi spingono a calci verso
quel traguardo ma io mi perdo rallento
inciampo cado mi rialzo cado mi rialzo
cado mi rialzo e l'incanto
è veramente resto immobile come un
abbandono una statua manichino
ma dentro ci sono io ho io sono quella
fuori e dentro insomma siamo due
quando sono in trance è come se fuori
fossi morta ma dentro quell altro è viva
e quella fuori non sa che potrebbe fare
qualunque cosa ma io rimango lì in
moglie immobile cerco di essere come gli
altri
tool davvero tutti i giorni se felice di
cucinare
e
chi ha figli
qualcuno anzi una mano vi prego per la
speranza del futuro
tu davvero tutti i giorni anni tuoi
figli
ecco vedi la sincerità è vivo abbiamo
abbiamo raggruppato sinceri
ecco chi è sicuro di non essere matto
io personalmente sono nata per volare su
una stella ma l'impressione più passano
gli anni e più sento forte di non essere
di non avere l'attitudine per la vita di
fuori
io sono più brava con il dentro scrivere
sotterrare tacere parlare da sola far
girare le rotelle dei pensieri tirapani
ceppari gli ingranaggi e la sensazione
di una di una porta dentro cui mi devo
infilare in fretta prima che si chiuda
per sempre
e dietro quella porta
c'è la mia stella
perché io sono nata per volare sulla
stella
questo diceva anne sexton
e io credo che noi tutti siamo nati per
volare su una stella e forse chi ha
figli deve insegnare volare sulle stelle
rileggete il piccolo principe adesso che
siete grandi perché forse poi più libro
per adulti che per piccoli e allora
quello che mi viene di dire è che non
dobbiamo accontentarci al che quando
incontriamo qualcuno di vederlo e basta
facciamo domande cerchiamo di andare
scrutiamo l'invisibile perché li
troveremo noi stessi e l'altro
siamo tutti nati
per volare su una stella pare che io
abbia ancora 4 minuti e 57 e allora
siccome siamo in questa cittadina che
amo in questa regione io sono pugliese
anche
vogliamo finire cantando una canzone
non c'è la musica la musica anche quella
potrebbe essere invisibile
e la dedico a questa terra è alle stelle
e a voi
solo per te
convinco le stelle
a disegnare nel cielo infinito
[Musica]
qualcosa che somiglia a te
solo per te
[Musica]
io cambierà pelle
per non sentir le stagioni
passare senza di te
[Musica]
come la neve
non sa
coprire
tutta la città
come la notte non faccio rumore
se cado è per te
come la notte non faccio
rumore se cado a parte
prendetevi voi stessi e abbiatene cura
sempre
ciao
[Applauso]